Châu nay, thủ tưởng chính phủ phạm mình chính đã đến thông Trung tâm báo chiếc đại hội mối mũi bũi của đăng,
tại Trung tâm hội hiểu của gia, lộn vien đợi mũi những người là báo tăng nghiệm tại đại hội.
Tổ tưởng chính phủ phạm mình chính biểu sân tinh thành làm việc hàng sai chắc nhẹn của các nhà báo phòng viên trong quá chính tác nghiệp,
đưa tin về đại hội mối mũi bũi của đăng. Thủ tưởng yêu cầu lãnh đạo Trung tâm báo chiếc tà báo, điều kiện cạnh thiết về có sở và chất,
trong thiết bị đường duyền. Tạo tưởng lợi tốt nhất để các nhà báo phòng viên tác nghiệp. Thủ tưởng đến nghĩ các nhà báo phòng viên tiếp tục đưa tin
kì thời chính xác mà sinh đậu về đại hội mối mũi. Đặc biệt là những tiềm mối trong công tác tổ chức đại hội và các phân kệ này hội.
Nhất là những lộn phá của đại hội lên này như tổ bị thư tổ lâm, đã nhấn mạnh tại phyên khai mặt đại hội.
Tâm diên phải chính lợp, tư duy về đột phá, hành động bị tối đẹp. Tủ tưởng chính phủ cũng người lời cảm ơn,
khi nhận lợi gũ những người là báo các cơ quan thông bình báo chi trong nước phó của tế đã nữ lực cô gắng tên chuyển hiệu quà,
lãn tòa giữ lợi xung của đại hội đến tất cả trong nước phó của tế. Về đại hội đà lên từ mấy bốn,
sư kiện chính xịt đặc biệt quan trọng của đất nước.